Well. Well, well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Judge, judge, judge, judge, judge, Judge
Mommy.
Yeah,
right,
sure.
Wow.
Wow. That's a, this mommy's
right by terrible productions.
Really good. Yeah. I like it a lot. Yeah.
So official
Newport by the vinyl is
a look. There's a lot of
crazy day changes coming up.
I Dunno if somebody, you
know this, they're not,
there's already been some
changes to the odd ball schedule.
So instead of listing them all, I'll just
tell you, if you want to come see me,
do stand up in your town,
go to [inaudible] dot com
there are some for sure.
My own shows are definitely going down.
Louisville, San Francisco, Manfred,
disco, Jude or titties. Um, with the
other one that I'm doing. Fill her up.
Delphia uh, Charlotte, North
Carolina, they're all at Tom,
cigarette.com. West Palm Beach.
I'm doing the Improv in December.
Um, and yes, we added all meets West Ball.
Meats are in a sweaty
balls are in December.
It wet ball means wet ball meats.
So make sure you that in Philadelphia we
added a third show filler of though the
Trocadero foot rest. It's
a dog. Oh yeah. Uh Huh.
Um, yeah, of course they're
registered. Uh, what about you?
I know you're taking a fabric
thousand ranch dot. Yeah.
I go to meet Rattle Portland.
I'm going to Dallas.
I'm going to Houston post and I'm
going to indie mom nap Indianapolis.
I'm going to a Cincinnati where the
notorious Cincinnati fart happened.
Oh my God. Did it ever. Yeah. Stupid APP.
Thousand ranch.com. Check
it out. Oh checkout.
That's deep road two fuckers.
Yeah,
it's really good.
It's really picking up heat.
Everyone's talking about it on the street.
Couple big things.
Doing knows your mom's house.
podcast.com and not only now has of course
all the episodes links to the youtube
videos of it. Um, we
are now on Google play.
A lot of people have been asking about it.
Finally came through Google play.
It's another format that you
can listen to the show on.
A lot of people are into it,
android users and whatnot.
So if you're finding a way to lizard now
and you want Google play, were there,
uh, your mom's house, podcast.com also
has clips. A lot of people always ask us,
where did you find a clip of that? Go
to the clips page. You can see that.
You can see the free ring tones.
If you want to download free ringtones,
we have a bunch up.
We're going to add more so it's free.
It's on us ring tones from the
show. Um, we have the store,
don't forget to check out the store. The
double pipe classic, the bikes shirt,
bird is fat. Uh, the
Cincinnati fart poster,
they're all there in the store.
And of course if you're on the,
if you're on your mom's house,
podcast.com,
please consider shopping
through our Amazon banner.
If you do all the shopping you
would normally do on Amazon,
but you go through our portal
and it helps out the show. Um,
the coolest thing ever is that
patriarch, of course. Hey,
try and put that down guys.
Go ahead and check that out.
It's a lot of behind the scenes stuff.
Special bonus episodes,
episodes just for the hard
fucking core. Yes. An H
fan. There's a lot of hard
fucking core shift or over, uh,
and we actually put up the latest
was a, uh, what's it called?
The lie of episode live episode and
repairs was there hard fucking core.
That's what patriots for
the hard fucking core. Yup.
No fucking dilettantes listener
on that real fucking hardcore.
We had an incident at the live show too,
which was kind of interesting.
I won't spill the beans so to speak. It's
already up. It was it already, I mean,
no, I'm saying the, the
episode that bonus episodes up.
Yeah.
There's a guy in the audience who was
crazy and we ended up talking to him after
and he goes, he, he, he knowledged
us. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
He wasn't crazy though, right? It was,
it was just funny cause he held onto it
for so long. It's really funny actually.
I think, um, if it's not
up yet, it will be up.
We're going to upload that
segment because it was so fun.
It was so funny. Um,
yeah, a lot of good stuff.
So check out patrion.com put touch it
then the patrion.com/mom put the shit
down. Um, okay.
Are you ready? You Ready?
Yes, I'm ready. My,
the house from some
commercial. Uh, you ready?
Ready?
There's this snap time guys.
Put him back in his cage.
Ever feel good?
That's where that's from.
And Blue Band got a microphone
upgrade, right? Bluebell.
Oh, all over the map today. Here we go.
Same for sure.
If wish you were here right now so he
could see me with my big fat Pussy Lips.
I'm going to get this movie here.
This movie's getting me all wet.
This pussy pussy juices
dripping down my fucking legs.
[inaudible]
those
guys.
I came over that
we went on a weekend getaway
with baby jeans. Oof. Yeah.
Not, nothing funner. More fun than
travel with an eight month old.
She's a staycation. Jesus Christ.
Yeah. Yeah. We, we drove there,
but um, it's, you would,
you would get me a glass of penal grease
every night and every day you always do
this. Whenever I go like I want
to go get something, you go.
Wouldn't it be crazy if you said you
were going to the bar but you were really
just going to meet someone.
I was like,
like a guy in the bushes and you're like,
well yeah because what if that
that's really what's going on.
If that's a crazy scenario.
I know I am crazy by the way are also a
real serial killer because she laughed
maniacally at the thought
of killing a squirrel.
That was so funny. I was like
I only as much. It was like
no cause you were like, cause there
was a, it wasn't a scrolls, a rabbit.
The rabbit that's,
we were sitting outside and we saw it.
Adorable little rabbit just stayed there
and stayed there and eating and you're
like, how would I kill that? And I go,
you probably should snap it's neck,
trap it and then snap it's neck. And I
was like, no trap a rabbit. Just sure. No,
because at first I go,
what should I go?
I wish I had a 22 so I could
to bed too much. Fire Him. No.
For a rabbit that's true. Is a
fucking BB gun to kill a rabbit. Well,
I mean the 22 is not much more than that.
That's my point.
So I go at 22 and I was like, Oh,
I wish I had a rock right now.
Then I started just laugh,
just imagining my mother being there
because I was upset. She would be like,
you have a rock to kill us.
And also to ask her,
do you have a rock?
Like here's a thinking of the dumbest ways
to kill that, Randy. Like first of all,
why would you kill the rabbit meat?
There's not a lot of meat.
It's like eating a pigeon.
But what made you laugh the most was
the idea of throwing a rock to stun the
rabbit and then running over
there and snapping. Yeah.
Was like,
I'm crazy.
I'm a maniac.
Yeah.
But that's why I laugh at that stuff.
Like that guy talking about,
see that's Henry Portrait
of a serial killer,
but that wasn't a, that was a person's
neck. It's a movie. It's not real guy.
He's with the hooker and he gets it.
And then the guy goes
Henry,
because he just snapped.
You don't want to snap a rabbit's neck.
Let's pull up that,
you know for fuck's sake. No.
To, what about your grandma here?
Oh yeah.
We'll get to her in a scene.
What it is fucked up to even
thinking about killing a rabbit.
There's no reason the
meat's not that good.
You gotta be real desperate to
kill a rabbit. Jeez. And then,
and then we ordered room service
for breakfast and then we didn't,
we forgot to have them
clear it and we ate outside.
So there was all our food outside and
then we're sitting out there and we saw
our raccoons coming and we're like,
oh,
these motherfuckers are going to eat
all our food. And then we came back.
It was gone. It was like
shitty hard potatoes and stuff.
Where's the funny scene? What's
growing potatoes that the rabbit too.
It ate it and liked it.
Is this the scene here now for
we don't know. Yeah, here we go.
Oh, I just got it. It's the funny,
it's not funny.
It's the funniest fucking thing ever.
So at Henry's in here, go with his
buddy and they each have a hooker.
Tell me that his friend's
reaction isn't fun. Okay.
[inaudible]
what's going on?
Oh,
that we're going to keep her quiet.
What is snaps her neck?
You don't think it's funny
what? Rabid person? Killing a heart.
A little cute rabbits to me is just,
it's hilarious cause you outweigh it and
you're so much bigger than was. Yeah.
There's no reason to like snap his neck.
I'd rather snap 20 hookers. Not Correct.
But then a rabbit I would too. They're
so cute. Rabbits were super cute. Okay.
Does grow on trees, right? Yeah.
Right. Yeah. Are you with me? Hi You.
Where are you with me?
Oh
anyways,
so my grandma,
we opened with a clip of her doing
her thing and stuff like that. And um,
I'm here. She is, she's
great. She is great. Um,
so this is like, cause this is
always the thing you didn't know,
but remember when you first sent
out as a kid and not even as a kid,
I think it's a little bit older.
You hear about sex lines and
then I never actually called one.
I just heard recordings of them, you
know, like, cause they're super expensive.
Yeah. It's like, I once
had a roommate in college.
We lived with one guy and it was like
four of us girls and we all went for
Christmas vacation and he stayed
behind. We came home, he spent $600,
no phone, sex, phone, sex. And he paid it.
But we were like, really? Dude, really?
It's a lot. It's a lot. But back in
the late nineties, that's how you,
you jacked it was that or print.
And then you find out that there's call
centers and that nobody would you speak
to ever. It looks like what
you think they look like.
That was the big rub about these.
So they have a, yeah, this,
she looks like Mrs Kuhner
is my first grade teacher.
That is Mrs [inaudible] didn't look
so good. Why don't you just drive her?
Yeah. Uh, well, number one,
there's definitely teeth missing.
I don't think she has any.
Yeah,
she's got the big Ted Bundy glasses from
the fuzzy glass. They have big glasses.
Oh. Um, no Stevie, maybe Stevie. Stevie,
definitely the glasses and then like
a real feminine kind of cool haircut.
Soccer player. Yeah.
Tennis player, haircut.
They kind of the kind of cut
that says it's shut down.
I would say it's really shut down. Don't
touch my vagina. Soccer, tennis player.
Russia. Sirica 87 88 yeah, yeah, yeah.
Santana, sweetie. Bye. Hey Baby.
Yeah,
so this is kind of stepping in her.
Well it looks like she does it from her
home and that she checks in with the car
like so they patch her in and
then calls are routed to her.
You know what a cool job I think you make.
Hi, it's me. I'm getting ready
to launch the APP. Okay, thanks.
Well now this is web cam from bitch.
That was bitch. Are you? Are
you touching that?
If right now,
I mean look at this right here. Imagine
this is what you're jacking off to. Yeah.
Oh, this is what my grandma
used to urinate in this bed pan.
I don't even, that's a bed pan that, you
know what? That was so traumatizing me.
You told me that. That I've
actually blocked it out. Yeah.
Why wouldn't you walk over to the toilet?
Because this is old country. This is,
this is how they did it back in the
old country. Yeah. But during the day,
she saw how awesome the toilet was.
Right. But at night the thinking is,
I'm so tired.
I don't want to lose my sleepiness by
getting up and going to the toilet.
Oh, I just put the pad next to me.
I piss in the pot. Wait, what's,
tell me like the real mechanics
of it though, is it on the floor?
She kept it under the bed, so she
would like urinate in it, but I mean,
in the middle of the night.
And so what would share the bed?
So let's say she gets, she
would stand up obviously. Yeah.
And then you just squat
down. I'm guessing. I never,
I never slept next to her,
so I don't know. But she liked the
bed pad and then she would dump it.
My Dad would just beg her to stop doing
it and she, she wouldn't, she sold school.
But that, that, that does look like a
bedpan. Yeah. Yep. She's just, you know,
she looks like, to me it's
just looks like, uh, I mean,
and I apologize for ever this offense.
There's like a white trash piece of shit
she loves. She has that to
get that real scumbag smoker.
Smokers looked to her like really?
You know,
really just really looks like shit.
There's no real like,
you know how Chloe Savini seven Yay.
Can play white trash.
Perfect Sol in bloodline,
right?
Like she's such trailer trash and
then she kind of looks like bloodline.
It's Chloe's mother like
she's, yes. Just the eggs.
The exemplary piece of shit. Like
trashing. Yeah. This lady has got,
if you were an actor should get an award.
That's right.
He's really looking like it.
Right.
She's not here. God Damn fucking
asshole. If you're pressing oh boy. Yeah.
I want to take this God damn fucking
Dick and I'm going to read it straight up
tomorrow.
Okay.
Wow. I bet she got a lot of guys
off back in her. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's some dude isn't, can you know what
I like about this though? She is a vet.
You can tell.
She knows like if you're comfortable
enough to be describing drinking coffee.
Drinking coffee. Yeah, laying back. She's
reclining in her house. She's not nervous.
It's just got the bad parent next door.
She knows that. Oh, this is old school.
Yeah,
15 years. Funny Shit. She's
doing jigsaw puzzle right now.
I'll tell you one thing for God damn
fucking shirt that you can know,
like that guy gave him fucking shit.
That's our,
we'll have you suck his dick.
I love her. She pretty great. It's
her name. Do we have a name or
hey inches long. Oh my. She's knitting.
Yes. Oh No, I don't
think I should catch it
plays all the different,
I know she's a sweet grand and
a shower and that's about it.
No, I didn't have, he would have my
things right before another camp.
Campex not nap.
If you don't meet my back door here,
she can play submissive or she can be,
this is a real talent.
I mean, I could never do
this. It's probably depends on
the call. Right? Right away.
She knows if it's from this
number of that line, like the dom,
the missive, the granted that call like
I'm logging in. They're probably like,
this is a dollar number. Right.
When she's like, you're assholes,
your pussy and like I'm going to fuck
you in it know. It's so fascinating.
Now do you think that they gave
her scripts and then she memorized?
Probably back in the
day somebody was like,
how this is how you do it when she started
back in the 20s now just note back on
the Oud phonograph or
are you coming?
Are you coming?
Yeah.
I tell you one thing for sure baby.
I wish she were here right now so you
could see me. I think that Pussy Lips,
this got me pretty worked up
getting me all wet.
His eyebrows either. It's troubling now.
She has no eyebrows. It's rather there.
Is that a choice or covered by the
glass? The glass glass or a large, yeah,
it's really hot. Crazy neck
too. Interesting a lot.
But if you were desperate, this would
be 100% option for funding to pay bills.
And they were like, just talk to
people and talk shit. I tell you what,
I think this is way more
dignified than that thing we saw.
That was just an ass
with the two holes in it.
Remember that plastic guy showed us where
he reviewed it and you fuck fucking in
here. You put it all together, clean out
the chamber is and you're like, Whoa,
wait, what do you mean more dignified?
Dignified on whose end? The man. Oh,
I mean I'd rather you call it if it
was you, let's say. Yeah, I'd be like,
please call granny.
Versus like us having to conceal
this look at her and still call.
I mean there's no percentage,
but you mean just call phone sex people.
That's just more dignified.
Why, why versus fucking that
thing. Fucking that thing.
Okay, so here's the thing. All it
is, but that thing we're discussing,
it's like a woman's ass and her thigh.
So it's like a chopped up women,
which you like already.
I know this is fun.
And then it's an asshole and
a vagina and there's clean up.
So where are you going to clean that?
You're going to put that in the
dishwasher with all the other crap.
I guess you could leave it
in the shower and the shower.
So when I'm showering I'm going to
fucking step on your girlfriend.
Well I mean I could, I could matter to
the wall or something. That's disgusting.
It's so undignified.
So people understand it's a,
it's a toy to sex toys like a fleshlight,
but it's actually sculpted to
look like a woman's ass bitch.
And it's called, I think it's called
like fuck my ass or something. Yeah.
And then they made a black one so he
knows where the fuck my big black ass.
And the guy was looking at the difference
between the fuck my ass in the fuck.
My big black ass. It's
just color tone. Well,
I mean I'm all for like the flashlight.
I think that's more dignified
than the asshole cut up.
It looks weird and look at it. Keep it
under the bed, like your mom's bed pan.
And then where do you keep it?
We've got a kid.
How are you going to conceal that thing?
You know,
walk in and he's just like fingering
boat. It's a neat toy. My buddy.
And most people don't do that
until they're much older.
Oh yeah.
That him and I do it together.
We're tag teaming it
like which told you want
pal? I think. I think for me,
just the cleanup sounds disgusting.
Whatever. One of those things. Yeah.
How the fuck do you clean out something?
You just didn't like that he
said you just, they're connected.
So you flushed with water and the
one guy's going to do that. No, I,
I imagine a lot of loads stay
in there. Yeah, of course.
Just the coagulated mess
that is pretty raw. Yeah,
I did imagine sharing it with nut,
like sharing it.
You're all just like, Bro,
just happening right now.
Come
due.
There's dude sharing one of those things
right now. They're probably already,
you have to share it. Fleshlight
right out there are 100% gnarly.
It's normally when you see it in the
movies. What do you mean? In the movies?
There's movies where guys share
flashlights not flesh. I probably,
they're probably, yes, the probably
are movies that share that,
but there's movies where they share women,
they'll dump inside to get a little
more natural. To me it's more natural,
but it's kind of grody.
Right. It's not cool.
I don't know.
Like a guy finishes and then another guy
goes right in there and he's like, ah.
And then another guy and another
guy. Yeah. It's a lot of com.
That is a lot of time and that's a real,
that's pretty gnarly.
Like you're super green,
you're in a special class after that,
you're in a very, uh, does that
excite you at all though? That idea,
having a just miscellaneous loads
in me. Yeah, of course. Of course.
The more the merrier.
Right.
I picture a lot of guys kind of waiting
behind us a lot of times, you know,
excuse me,
picture like 20 guys waiting their turn,
you know, I don't know.
That's not a thing.
I can't wrap my brain
around to think for me.
I really,
because I never even had like one night
stands because of that because I don't,
I don't like the idea of just some,
some stranger ejaculating.
You picture like a prison group though.
Not like, oh, I guess like duct tape,
duct tapes back there. He's talking
a lot of shit. Stevie and yeah, yeah,
yeah. Areas has turned. It's
duct tapes. Yeah. Who's up next?
All right man.
Go ahead.
No boy.
I tell you one thing for sure.
They do not play with
you like your [inaudible].
My name is [inaudible]. I like to
do to call with my he really hard.
I didn't know that was coming.
How do you say
that was pretty gnarly, man.
Good one for her. Hey man,
she's making a living though.
You know she is.
She making people happy and it's not
televised, which is great. Yeah, right.
She doesn't have to do porn so her,
her life is intact. It's nice of,
they showed us her taking a week.
She did a mocking Asian voice.
Pay, pay, pay pee now.
Thank you very much.
You think you're going to drink all that
got a mother fucker to come straight out
chocolate together.
She's taking it on.
It's not on my stuff and Nasty
dos and you're going set.
Come on, God. Demo bucket.
Nasty ass bitch.
Oh, I love it. She's
doing house chores, man.
Basically the most veteran
vet all, yeah. Oh yeah.
She doesn't even blink while she teaches.
The others had to do it. This Brian.
Yeah. Good for her. Good.
Wow. I wish I could really,
I would love to hear her story. Oh, it's
probably a great curious. I wonder what,
how'd she know that we've called
her such trash and shit back?
He feels like a pretty nice lady.
Old. I don't think she's alive
anymore. I'm going to throw up.
Can we, can we move it
along? Okay. Okay. I do baby.
Oh yeah. Your accent. Oh No. Black men
don't have anything. Adixen white men.
The only difference is the
Goddamn the fucking cal and baby.
I can promise you that fucking shit.
Reading a book and doing it.
That's how good she is.
So fucking it really hard for
you honey. Okay. Black. Really?
Wow. Holy Moly. Wow. What a
smarty, what a smarty smarty pants.
She sure I'd be. Would you ever
do that for a living? Yeah. Yeah,
I would give us a taste. What
of your phone? Sex style. Oh,
what type of color is it?
Okay. Um, I'm just a shy girl.
Okay. So I've never done
anything before. You say bitch,
you shy? Yeah, I'm scared of it. Kind of
tits. You got, what's your debt situation?
Hanky low hanging. Hello? Yeah.
You like having your tense,
your tits pinched at all, Huh? You like,
um, well I'm scared. I
don't you ever have your,
this is like the first time we did
it this way. Grab your tits slice
and see really good job. Thanks for coming
in. Oh wait, I was just getting more
cause they will validate your parking.
I was getting excited. That was fun.
You slice those tits up. Yeah, that's how
you do. You'd be like slice your tits.
What if I, what if I cut your nipples
off and let them bleed all over the desk?
Why don't you in the pussy
right now? Exactly. What if I,
what if I put two thumbs on your
butt hole and then pull them apart?
That is kind of how I
start ripped her anus.
That's how I started every
lovemaking session. Well
with, you know, my whole life.
Yeah. That's really how, that
was my move to the button
and then as soon as I heard it,
I would come.
I can throw a,
uh,
it was fun. That was fun.
Uh, we have some break.
It's major news.
Had chips in a bowl in a long time.
Well, you, um,
fif is really looking at this deck.
You said,
she says that this was news,
right?
It appears
that's pure free flicking his
boss. So. Wow. Yeah. Geez.
He doesn't have bolded the
deck. It appears that, um,
the legends is back. That's right. Yeah.
We just received a news this morning
that our beloved is returned to work.
The most talented actor of all time,
who we thought retired actor is adult.
Officially back
my ass.
My ass.
I thought he was retired for good. I
mean he made quite a statement, but,
but it's like Jay z when he always says
he's retiring and then he makes another
album. It's like they can't
stay away. Listen, when you're
good at something. Yeah.
The God works through you. You're
not doing the work, you know?
And he felt inspired and he
went back to work. Well he, um,
I shouldn't put this on the screen,
but yeah, it looks like because we,
how can we play the grandma? I guess
that's, that was on youtube community.
I wonder if I can dare just
no insertion this video.
Thank God there was an assertion
with grandma this a night.
This is pretty intense. Okay. Um, I'm
trying to see if I can play any of it,
but how about just the audio? Okay. I
don't need to see it cause anyone else.
Yeah, I think I would be really heavy on
the porn today. It's very porny today.
Yeah. Yeah. Let's, uh, maybe we
should maybe not listen out loud
in your cubicle
Max security alert.
Immediate life
one eight.
What
is that? That is a Mac
alert going off. It's like,
cause you're watching porn. Oh yeah.
It's a virus and knows all
about it. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right. Okay. So, uh, yeah. Oh,
it's the whole scene here. I didn't
want to see the whole theme, so yeah.
Rocco's definitely back
though. Well, I thought,
I thought it was just
like a little trailer.
I didn't think I was being
sent the whole thing. Yeah.
Um, well it's neat that he's
bad. God dammit. Why is this?
God Damn you guys hear the news listening.
We got an email from a listener.
Yeah, Rocco. Yeah, he's back.
He's back. I the world of porn. There's
just not enough people doing it, you know?
No one's doing it anymore,
so it's good to have somebody
who's committed to the game. Um,
poor guy.
It looks like he's just as
committed and aggressive as ever.
His films, I don't like that.
He's so rough sometimes.
He's got a big hog on him.
I like his attitude.
I like his enthusiasm. You know,
he married a Hungarian lady,
Kevin with that. Yeah. I mean,
is that Your Hall Pass Guy?
My Hall Pass Guy. Rocco's yeah. Everyone
has a hall pass. Right? You're like, ah,
that, that Land Ryan Gosling. Really?
He's your hall pass. So who
is your hall pass? I Dunno.
Probably Rocco. Stop it. What?
Megan Fox before her face got all weird.
What happened to her face?
She's too much plastic surgery, but she
didn't need, plus she was perfect before.
She did not need that.
She looked like somebody actually
drew her and she was pretty weird.
Um, Charlise tear on. No, but I like
her. I think she's great. Charlie.
Charlie's Tehran is great. She
speaks Afrikaans. No. Yeah,
she's real smart. She's real
smart. She's real smart. Uh,
so anyways, this is, fuck man,
this is fucked up my whole computer
watching on now. Yeah. All right.
I'll get out of it. That's why you got to
watch it on your phone right now. Okay.
Here's a good shot I can show. I think.
I think I can show this. All right. Uh,
right there. Can you see that during the
movie? There's some saliva right there.
Oh Gosh. Okay. All right.
Okay. Yeah. So do you think he's a little
old to be doing a little, yeah, no,
he's way old to be doing. And it's
Ron, Jeremy retired. He doesn't know.
He still does it. Oh, gross. And he
needed, yeah, he said stop. Yeah,
it's a, but again, he was
always kind of a regular body,
if you know what I mean. Ron.
Jeremy. Yeah. That was his thing.
He's like a regular body.
Rocco is 52. Wow. Yeah.
So as of 2011, he has
started in 1300 films. 1,350,
man.
Yeah. I just, I wonder,
okay.
I mean I have, we've asked this
question before when we had jewels,
Ventura in here,
how it affects your personal life.
Like you fuck for a living and then you
come home and doesn't that kind of ruin
it for you and you're just,
you know, it's like Cami,
you and I don't watch sitcoms.
We don't watch comedies cause
that's what you do for a living.
You've pride rather vomit than
watch. I agree. So who knows?
They have member at the uh, um,
take a joke. What's it called?
Can we take a joke and we take a drug
from here, the guy who I was like, oh,
that guy
who asked the question. Yeah, that's
him. Oh. So we did a Q and a for,
can we take a joke premiere?
And this guy had a question for me.
I guess what the for us, look what he
found it. He's the founder of evil angel.
He had a second amendment question.
Yeah. Oh, that's so interesting.
And I'm not a huge fan of evil as a brand.
I'm just not interested in
like [inaudible] crap. Oh he's,
he's also known as black man. It says,
oh, I know, but man, the button man,
I'm thinking of Fart man.
Nevermind. Well he did for him. He,
he also used to, I guess employee
are good. Betty Yoshi. That's right.
Who's been on your lot and Yoshi does not
like them anymore for sure. Oh God, no.
Well, here's, here's why he's so
big on that. In the end, 2008,
he was indicted on federal
obscenity charges, um,
by a federal grand jury in DC.
Hmm.
And he launched a website then all about,
you know,
that and then a federal trial
began with him as a defendant,
but all charges were dismissed. So
he's a very, um, you know, proac
he's, he's really at the
center of all that kind of
exactly. Debate. Wow. So yeah,
he was, he was at that
premiere. Wow. I know.
Cause right away it's
interesting how you know who the,
the famous porno people
immediately, you're like, I
know that guy. He's in Cornell.
Yeah, of course you do. He's
behind. He's an owner though. Yeah.
But that guy is so he does a lot of press.
He does interviews all the time.
He's not a performer. I pro stock
performer by stone. Oh yeah.
He can get hot anywhere. That's what
Yoshi upset it. But what about him?
But I tried to bait him in to that.
The guy is like,
he can get hot and wet as this big thing.
Yeah.
That guy can fucking any
condition and strong performer.
That's what they're always looking for.
[inaudible] it's hot out. That's it.
Get hard. It's hard, I guess.
Yeah. I mean difficult.
We should say it like that is probably
the most difficult thing. Yeah.
Cause you have to block out all
the other stuff. The cameras,
the lighting pressure to come.
Okay now come like that's,
that is a talent that is
really a talent Molly. Wow.
Things got really dirty today. Yeah.
I that happened dad. It's your fault.
My fault. You open with that. No, I
did an old lady. I love that lady.
She was a sweet lady.
Um,
this kid, have you seen this? I
wanted to show you this, this kid.
Well actually I want to tell the
story first about, about, um,
cause this happens sometimes.
What happened when I went
to the bar last night.
So that did, yeah. Before I
met that dude. So this guy,
uh, I walked up to the
bar and he goes, hey,
I know you and I go, yeah.
And so I got to tell you,
I never want to presume that somebody
like that definitely knows who I am.
Like I don't think like that. Like
this guy probably really does know me.
Cause sometimes people don't know you
and they think they know you. Right.
But still, this dude was adamant
that he knew me. Right. So he goes,
I definitely recognize, you know, it was,
it was funnier than that though. He goes,
I definitely recognize you. And I go,
yeah. And he goes, where do I know
you from? And I said, I don't know,
because I don't want to assume
that it's what I think, you know,
and you can't be a Douche bag and be
like, have, I'm a famous comedian. No,
it's so gay. So it is, and you, it
would program. Sorry. It was, yeah,
you shouldn't say that. You're
so non-binary. So he goes, um,
he goes, did you play college
football? I got like such an erection.
I wish that's what you knew me
from. You know, it was like, God,
why can't that be true? So I go like,
world's biggest cock. And I know
he was called trouble. And I go, no.
And he goes, did I paint your hot rod?
And I go, no. And he goes,
did I pave your driveway?
I go, oopsie yeah. I'm
like, no, sir. And he goes,
uh, we play the poker
league together. Nope.
Very colorful life. And he goes,
are you a marine? And I go, no.
He goes, shit man thought was
one of those five. I guess not.
Yeah, I'm pretty amazed. And
then I, I still didn't go,
well I'll volunteer. What I think he goes,
he just stayed there and he goes, God,
I fucking recognize you.
And I go, no man, that's,
that's, I, I don't,
he goes and have you ever been down to
like you spend a lot of time in Long
Beach? And I go, no.
And I saw it like that.
He was really trying and obviously
he tried all those, you know,
that his different guesses.
So then I kind of go like,
cause sometimes you just go like, all
right, and you just walk. I go, I go,
all right. He, cause he kept looking
at me. I go, uh, I don't know.
Did you have to have Netflix? And he goes,
yeah. I go, well I have, uh, a couple,
uh, stand up specials on Netflix.
And he goes, Nah, that's not it.
I go, okay. He goes, it's gotta
be something else. I go, I mean,
I guess it could be something else,
but that would be the biggest
exposure I've ever had.
Nobody believes you when you tell them
where they know you from for the longest
time. But I know you and I'm like, it's
from road rules 1999 that's not it.
I'm like, Eh, it trust me.
I know we didn't go to high
school together as soon as
I said that. And he goes,
that's not, he goes, I go, you sure?
And he goes, I've met you personally.
And then I go,
then probably the Marine Corps.
I wish you guys did go to. And then did
you blow him behind the Bush or after?
After that 21 minutes.
Yeah,
we pounded some booze. I got
blackout and you know, anyways,
there's to do that on the down
low on family vacations. They,
naughty boys do that. They cruise and
they look for other dudes. Yup. To blow.
And then they blow him. Really?
Naughty boys really dad it out.
We went to the pool, we took our
little jeans to a swimming pool.
I'm going to post the
picture on Instagram. Um,
it's so funny you put sunblock on your
face but you forgot to do under your
eyes. So it, it was like
caked on white, white, white,
and then just your eyes and your under
eye circles were like perfectly cut out
of it.
Like you look like a raccoon and you're
such a dad and that was so white and
creamy. Like you hadn't even rubbed it
in and all it can even try soundbites.
Sankin burned bad. I
want to get a burn. Uh,
so cute. It's so hot out. How can you,
but you didn't think to like rub it in
and that's how far I rubbed it in to that
level. Yeah, I didn't care. That's
what happens when you're a kid.
You don't care. Yeah. And then I feel like
you should acknowledge me for my fart.
God, there was so obscene
that you did that. I mean,
there was so many nice people
just enjoying their day.
Christina walks up and she just goes like,
it's like five feet from
these people at the,
they're eating lunch by the pool and
I'm like, he's us. And she's like, well,
fucking deal with it. Did not say,
well, deal with it. She goes, smelter,
bat like that, and I was like, Whoa,
no, I blamed it on you. I went, Tom.
Yeah, Dad. It was really not cool.
It was really gross and I was
wearing a wet bathing suit,
so it had that special kind of snap to it.
Little pop.
He did it twice.
Then another one,
I know you did it this morning too,
right? I've been fighting a lot,
but whenever I eat in restaurants and
I eat a lot of meats at restaurants,
I flirt. Yeah, it's pretty neat.
You don't see it all the time,
but then sometimes you do.
What was that stupid movie you were
watching last night? Oh my God.
First of all, for the guys that I meet
out in the, in the parks and in the,
just wanted to show this.
Oh,
the Senate certainly can bring about a
censure resolution and it's a slap on the
wrist. It's a bad boy. Bill
Clinton. You're a naughty boy.
The American people already know that
Bill Clinton is a bad boy. A naughty boy.
I'm going to speak out for the citizens
of my state who in the majority think
that Bill Clinton is probably
even a nasty, bad naughty boy.
It's the weirdest, the greatest
thing ever. And then of course,
he famously was trying to get a B Jessel's
in the Minneapolis airport and he was
arrested Bj's, Bj's, blowjob. Yes.
So he was tapping his foot
under the stone. That's him.
Disgraced senator. Yeah. Yeah.
That's what they say. Those who call
out the other ones or I like, oh,
and here's the two pastors
that do it. It's the worst.
They're always like that. Ted Haggard
was homophobic, hating the gaze,
and then he was doing the same shit.
I watched 13 hours last night, or most
of it, I think that's what it's called.
It sounded like it's equivalent of a
chick flick for dudes where it's all just
like talk and macho.
It's about a horrific and terrible
thing. You know, it's the,
the attack on the, um, on
Bengazi, right. The, the,
the attack that happened in 2012 a bunch
of people died. Embassy, right? Yeah.
Um, and I hate it. Didn't do well.
Uh, it was bad. It was,
it was weird thing was
they took this real story,
but they laid a blueprint of a,
just a regular action flick around it.
In other words,
you've seen a million action movies
that there's no reality to it. I said,
but this time they go,
this is about Benghazi,
but we're going to make it like a fun
Bro Action Movie. And it's a battle,
a real thing. And they all had,
um, the Afghanistan beards,
like they were out in the shed, the,
uh, special ops beards and they,
you know what the guy shows up
who's not part of the inner circle,
who are you? And he's like, we're fuckery
Taylor. They'd be seal. And he's like,
he's a good one. Fuck that guy. And
like all that stuff. And then, um, yeah.
And then, uh, it was also
throughout the film, uh,
an on again, off again,
commercial for Mercedes,
five different new Mercedes model cars
in Libya post post revolution Kadafi fall
into a brand new, uh, g five 15.
Yeah. Okay. All these new Mercedes. And
it was to the point where you're like,
this is a Mercedes commercial, like
this is getting uncomfortable, you know,
like they wouldn't even swap out.
I have some different cars. Um,
and they said fuck a lot. Like
very superfluous use. Yes,
he's fucking windows. You can't
see fucking shit out of here. Like,
why did you even need to say fuck?
And my fifth establishing scene was main
character facetiming back to the house
boy. And his wife was like, hey baby.
And he's like, how are the girls?
And the girls were like, Hi
Daddy, he's looking at miss.
You guys really miss you guys. And then
you see him in danger and he's like,
I'm just my girls, he's making a video to
send back to me. This is all I fucking,
then the wife was pregnant, I
was pregnant, I was pregnant.
And the guy's like, oh my God, I'm a
dad too. And like, it's just so dumb.
And you realize, I don't know,
once you've seen, you know,
movies for 30 years like I have,
I feel like when you see the blueprint,
like when you see how it's done,
you're like,
this is just the same fucking,
why would anyone feel entertained by
this if it's dummies? Just the formula.
So Warren,
the same reason sitcoms over and over,
people like just formula according to
this, I don't know if it's 100% true.
It says the movie was made for 45 million.
That sounds really low as a small budget
for a Michael Bay movie that says box
office was 69, so that's not good.
That's not good. $20 million.
I just,
I saw one scene before I went to sleep
where they're checking out the embassy
security and the guy's like,
he's fucking breaches in these walls.
There's not enough.
We're sitting fucking ducks right here.
It's a lot of like macho deck slaps.
It's really dumb.
It's a really dumb make. Slappers
um, he and all his movies,
he did Pearl Harbor. That was the same
kind of thing. Even facetime and that,
you know, God damn it.
That's right. It's like 1940
this isn't working so good. Cause I got
bad was I love you too. Fluffy Jacks.
Yeah. That's awesome. Speaking
of awesome movies. Yeah,
let's check out the new
C
[inaudible].
You see what they do now for him
is that they,
they cut in lieu of showing him moving.
That was an action sequence,
right? It was, instead of
showing him doing the thing,
there were like six cuts.
So you don't see his enormous body
trying to do this complicated.
Yes. They fake movement with
other people. Moving. One, two,
three, four, five, six,
six cuts. Yeah. Wow.
Yeah. That's incredible. Yeah, and they're
like, he just kicked that guy's ass.
I saw it in six different frames.
[inaudible] I throw blows
comes in small black dress.
I have vocal fries and tends
to man, that's, by the way,
he's a million years old
and the girl's like 19 yeah,
it's a million years. That's not the,
that's not the girl for you, Bro.
That's not the girl for you to travel.
Always gives in a little blade here
that you're of course paying attention.
That vocal fry. Uh, Joe, uh,
come to the black.
The black
sure blowers comes small.
Black dress. Nice. Huh?
Sorry.
Much a boyfriend.
His eyes were swollen. Shut so
much sausage the night before.
Filming Beer. Whose boyfriend?
That is just the clothing.
That's just bloat. Yup. Check. Do we have
his yellow sunglasses? All right here.
Actions.
Barney had a lot of money.
Of course, a sea gal is famous for
the entire film being in the trailer.
Could you get it for me?
$2 million
that bad. Technically it's
not stealing. Kindness
can make this happen. You
don't have the time. Do you?
Don't get the money.
It's always bad guys too.
He's always fighting the bad guys to
see how little he was emoting in that
statement,
that plan to get that
money is bad guy like that.
Like there's nothing behind those eyes.
There's no emotion.
No dead for me. It do you have a plan?
Do you have a plan? Steven Sea Gal?
Don't get the money.
Go get them. Go get the
money. He got a little,
it might as well ask the grip
to read the learns, you know?
Do you think that was Asiany? Yeah. Plan
to get the money. I don't. Or Latin.
Maybe you get the money like a Cholo.
He does like that.
He blacks it up a little
one. Oh, he does that.
So he put the black on the end
of that one. Get the money.
Don't get the money. No, that's
Asia. Sorry. How's this concrete?
Yeah, we're rich. Yeah.
Now it comes to the problem here.
Yeah. Got The money. Let me guess.
The gangsters are going to come after
them for stealing the money. My money.
My money. One way or another. Yes sir.
I'm looking for a man and a woman.
She looks like a cop.
She looks like a stripper.
She looks like like a
cop. She looks like a,
he said she right, right.
You think they would take that line again?
I mean we got to
roll guys. Maybe Caresa clearly. Right?
She looks like a cop. She,
let's see. Yes. Makes it
for a man and a woman. She looks like
a cop. She looks like this trooper,
why would you,
why would you leave that in the trailer?
This is a major thousand
dollars production. You're
not going to shoot the lines,
right? Or place the audio afterwards
in post or something. That's a quick,
that's because the girls editing
this himself on his iPhone.
I'm looking for a man and she,
she looks like a cop.
She looks like a stripper.
Oh my goodness. Unreal.
On real.
I cannot believe that that
good for a man and a woman. She looks
like a cop. She looks like this stripper.
Okay.
Yeah.
Do you think when he's in the,
this is clearly in Europe, right?
Shooting in foreign countries.
This is for sure. Oh yeah.
This was a Middle East actually to
no, come here and look. Oh, right.
That was supposed to be, yeah,
that's probably right. Yeah.
So when he's there that people think,
oh,
this is a major production,
this is a huge movie. And then,
then he's like, no, we're
making this for like $30,000.
But I mean,
to his credit,
he comes out with a movie every five
months or something. More than that. Yeah.
Every three months he comes out
with a new movie. Absolutely.
It's similar in structure.
Money. All right. Now
like kill me.
Isn't this the exact premise
for the last year that we watch?
That's what I'm saying. It's all the
same. I mean, exactly. Exactly the right.
There's some girl and,
but he didn't do Kung Fu with her yet.
He hasn't had the scene where he's like,
oh, he fingered. Yeah, they fingered.
That's why they're attacking.
Sure.
Hello there. How can up, I know,
but will they do Kung Fu together?
Oh, shutting seems like this as time. So
you think it's creepy to shoot a
sexy with him? He's old as fuck
ain't even cute. We still get to
that up. I bet that widow's peak. Oh,
it takes away Agra.
Just all black ink.
Do you think he comes black ink?
Because it is so it is now and stuff.
Yeah.
Do you think
could have walked through
where we the money
you'll pick up balls. Sense.
Thank you for noticing. Wait,
if he's about the honor,
why would he steal 2 million in the
first place? Does it makes no sense.
There's no trying to break down
our fucking premise to this.
Just roll with it. Okay. He got Lionsgate
though. That's pretty good. Theaters,
theaters, production value on this
one is definitely, it is much better.
It is way better. There's a lot better
to, somebody stepped up on this one.
Maybe they saw our last podcast about
what if a, they're like, oh shit,
this house is on us.
Um,
I wonder how many movies he's in
pre production on 37 a movie a week.
Well actually you know how many came
out in 2016 we're in 2016 yeah, right.
2016 there's one, two,
three, four, five, six. Wow.
Six wow. And next movies. That's
a movie a month. Killing Salazar.
Sniper. Special ops code
of honor in connection with
the Asian connection. Yeah.
End of a gun contract to kill his filming
and attrition is in preproduction for
next year. What did, but he is just,
she found some investors and he has crank
and then which ones did we just watch
a gun? You know what? I bet they did.
Cause I think Lionsgate gate picked up
Tyler Perry's first few movies as well.
They bought like 10 Tyler Perry
movies for like a million each.
Bundling them.
And that's how he became so well known.
And then this guy at this point,
you take your guys like him
take it off the top right.
So what happens is a studio will go like,
oh,
we're going to only gonna give you
like $2 million to make this movie.
And he goes, my fees a million. Right?
And then he may have to make the move.
Makes it for $10,000 the whole movie,
my fee is $1,000,989 yeah.
But he's smart. He's doing it. He's
maintaining his own career with these,
you understand that there's a,
there's a demand.
And then I've always loved
his imdv bio Stevens,
a gauzy strikingly and
somewhat boyishly handsome,
often with a ponytail action star
tense. Right. He definitely wrote
that Shit, man. Of course he did.
Of course. He was like, let me see
was the most beautiful way.
Striking. Yeah. Shit. I'm striking.
They speaking a Kung Fu.
Speaking of
teeth people we've talked about,
talked about a frosting with,
uh,
and how there's a whole push again, push.
I know, but there's some new information.
Now you might be wondering
what is oil pulling?
Oil pulling is a very simple thing.
It became in a high quality vegetable oil.
I prefer coconut oil because
it's other healing qualities.
Taking it about a tablespoon of it,
swishing it around in your mouth.
And as you're swishing
around this raw fat,
the enzymes in the fat
literally pull bacteria,
pass and toxins from your body.
What's Your Pronoun? Uh, like, uh, uh,
I'll be like, hey, what's your product?
What's wrong? What's her pronoun?
What's its prolean? I don't think
it's a straight hair. Zoom. Zoom.
Which Brent in the fuck
is she talking about?
I think it makes sense.
What does Zim talking about?
Got To wash your two
fees with animal fats.
So let me show you real quickly how
you do it. Oh, please do. Here's why.
Coconut oil, coconut oil, coconut oil.
I'm going to vomit already. Put
it in your mouth. Fuck off shores.
You're swishing around.
Do not swallow it because you'll be
in basically adjusting the toxins that
you're pulling. So there we go. Put
it in your mouth. Five to 15 minutes.
Five to 15 minutes.
And that's on the low end.
I've been saying some that say 20 minutes.
Can you just swish it around your mouth
for 20 full minutes or just switching
stop
or you can just floss.
No stupid.
Can't just floss.
Fucking idiot.
I love all these urine therapy.
Coffee enemas.
Swishing coconut oil.
Why?
Why do we need these alternatives to
systems we already have in place that are
working pretty damn good.
Last works.
Cold medicine works.
There's a knock on,
on your whole floss though.
People are saying it's bullshit.
Yeah,
but what about just getting food particles
out of your teeth like after you eat
statements though? True, true. Um,
a lot of people were so gross, so, so,
so in love with top dog. Oh Em. Gee,
his last joke.
Oh Man.
Let's revisit some of the highlights
because it's so funny. Yes. I've,
I've spent time just reminiscing over that
just alone, you know, just hanging out,
thinking about how epic it was.
Hey Buddy, stop dog Kate, buddy.
Stop Dog. Take Buddy. Stop. Doc.
Do you need to wipe down the top dog?
Um,
he really goes such a good call
with a top dog was on the phone.
We called and we just, I know that he
loves street jokes. So we started reading.
I'm blonde jokes.
Oh my God.
He lost his mind.
He laughed.
So he said stuff that was so just him,
you know what I mean? Like, it
was so genuine to who it was.
So authentic on that call Tom Bride.
Okay.
Loved it down broad blind Joe.
Yeah.
Ah, I love blonde jokes, by the way.
Yeah. And he laughed so
hard in this so hard. Yeah.
Love it.
His laugh is the best. Love those
jokes. Oh, I got a little pod junk
for the easiest, just simple as broke. He
said, do you remember? He's on that call.
He goes, sometimes I'll just say a
joke like that to myself and laugh.
And I'm like,
what?
He uh, he really likes telling him too.
He kind of stretched them out a bit.
Like he adds more detailed than you need.
Yeah.
Cause that's how much he enjoys
telling him. I think he wants to talk.
I mean I've never had
money.
One job when I went out,
the only time I heard him laugh like this
was when we went out to, we went
out to a uh, a breakfast I met,
I went with him and a 90 year old man,
I'm like 90 years old.
Those two were telling each other street
jokes and my dad was laughing this
heart and by the way,
the 90 year old man was too.
I thought I was going to watch him die in
front of us. I've never seen something.
He was like, oh like shaking. And
then he was like, now you do one.
To me that was the old guy who I was like,
I don't have jokes like that.
And he was like, why? He didn't understand
comedians don't,
when you ask them to tell a joke it's
cause we don't tell street jokes. Right,
right, right. That's from like the old
time Shecky Greene and shit like that.
Exactly. Red Button. Yeah.
Oh I got
you thought that was really funny.
You know
that's really funny.
Are such corn cornball jugs too.
I told her that only
coaches going to London.
How are they against? Hilarious.
Yeah.
Good Rod.
That broad as really dates
as you know who he is.
Yeah.
That's my favorite part of that joke
cause it's some dumb broad would find that
really tickles him.
That really when women are dumb
really gets is get some broad. Yeah.
Like,
like when your mom does something silly,
he just loves to report
the news back to us. Yeah.
You know what your mom did today. Bribes
are different. He says that to me.
Sometimes you don't if
you're talking like, yeah,
you know my sister did it and he's
like, Tommy brands are different. Yeah.
That's like his loves that Shit.
I love that expression
and the blinds. So did I, but I
thought you might change his mind.
How does it answer? It's hard. I
think that's hilarious. Oh my God.
Wait,
that's so funny.
And the thing is,
he's told these jokes and countless times,
this is not the first time that your
dad's regaled us with these blonde jokes.
He tells me that he's been telling me
these for you and he still laughs this
hard steel screws up. Usually the
setup and the punchline. Yeah.
Then they got the guy, he wants to know
he the other guy. The other guy came in,
I'm like, it's over. You already
fucked it up. And he's like, Huh, that.
It's really funny.
I can't remember how it goes.
What episode is the full conversation
and blue band that people can listen?
The 59 yeah. Is it? Yeah. The last one.
It's not in three 58 [inaudible]
59 actually, no. Yeah,
you're right through 58 three 15 okay,
so if you guys want to hear
the whole conversation,
listen to episode three 58 he also,
you can hear the,
the horrible jokes that were telling him
didn't understand the concept of these
are set up punch jokes. So I would say
set up and you just got to go like what?
It's like the knock knock who's there.
That's all you gotta do.
I would ask him,
I would do the set up and then he would
try to logically figure out the answer.
So I asked them like this Polish joke,
you know,
how do you know if you're in
front of a Polish firing squad?
That's true.
You spoke about how
the guns are faith. If the guy, dad sad,
do you not understand
how these jokes work?
You're not supposed to actually try it.
Yeah,
answer them
any and he did it multiple times.
Like right after that he does
it again. I know, I know.
He has to guess the punchline.
You can't let the biggest revelation was
him thinking that this is my act now.
Right. You thought you were asking
like 10 jokes into this and he's like,
these are good.
Like I don't know if you should do these,
but these are shooting my way. What? Like
you think this is how I do stand up now,
but do you think your dad laughs
this hard at your acne? No. No.
Never laughed as hard at math.
This is, you don't give any one liners
like this for, this is good stuff here,
buddy.
What would you please? Oh my
God. It would kill your career.
I heard that one before. Yeah,
that's a funny one actually. Yeah.
That's crazy,
right?
Hey,
he's laughing so hard.
Corny jokes. He corny Blonde
Joe. Straight up joke,
but just the loves them, man.
Yeah, it's a different time.
I guess they used to love, I mean, that's
how people would do. Take my wife please.
Here you see the people just fucking
fallen out of their seats. Yeah.
They're killing. Crushing
with that Shit. Unreal man.
How times have changed, haven't they
have? I've remembered a Polack joke.
I'm gonna. I'm going to tell her
that's pretty offensive. I'm a pole.
Like I can tell those jokes.
Okay. You can say it. Tell me,
how do you know a Polish girl is on her
period? Oh, she's only wearing one sock.
Oh,
that's funny.
Got Anymore. Let only think
about it. Okay. I don't know.
Okay. I know you got some racial
ones floating around in your head.
Of course. I rememorized the truly
tasteless joke book, but they're just,
they just feel mean now.
They don't even think two different times.
They don't feel funny. Yeah.
You know, we're in a new era.
Yeah, man. All my life I was born
in that. This always be a man,
but I don't understand that binary.
You're just man or woman.
People say about being nonbinary via
you're complicating things so much.
It's really not that complicated.
Why don't you just pick a gender?
Did you pick a gender?
You can't just make up words.
Do you think where it says grow on trees,
all words are made up so you're gay,
right? My sexual orientation has nothing
to do with my gender expression. God,
which bathroom do you use?
Probably the one that I'm less
likely to get harassed him.
But you wear suits but you wear dresses.
Yes.
But you put on makeup while spotted.
Why did you transition then?
Why are you so ignorant? But
what does it say on your id? Oh,
and that has none of your business so
vital to pick agenda. There you go.
And why do I agree with
all the shit people are?
Cause I watched it and I was like,
I agree with everything.
My impression of the 80 year
old third world. Yeah. What,
why are you complicating stuff? I totally
agree. But you're born a man, right?
You wear suits. Here's a news
flash. You're a fucking man.
We can't. And we gotta be real careful
with Ellis. We have to call him baby self.
Yeah. Maybe cause he can't choose his
gender and we're in it's child abuse.
Tom. I know. If we dress
him in blue, I gotta be real
cognizant of it. Yeah, I know.
Maybe self, toddler, so very um,
non gender specific clothing and colors.
What does toys?
No, no, definitely no gender toys.
I just give him plastic balls and
sticks that are yellow or green.
Well you know, I get him. Everything
I do, I get him stuffed animals.
I get them trains, I in books.
I don't know. Yeah, I really do.
I even see gender and I don't know,
I was at the store,
we went to buy buy baby to
get a new stroller. Yeah.
And the girls section
is terrifying though,
cause it's all like easy bake oven, how
to cook things. And then there's like,
it's a toy mop so you could start
cleaning sooner. The girl's section was,
it's really gender and the boys,
the boys too. I'm sorry. Yeah.
See, oh, game. And the girls is
like, how did keep a house clean?
How to blow the CEO, right?
Yeah, it was, it was really bad.
The girl stuff is pretty
appalling. Yeah. Yeah. Dump rods.
I can you press pause? I gotta get the
groceries. Yeah, sure. Oh, I dunno.
Anyways, so hydrated.
Uh, did you get the food?
I did.
I have groceries delivered so I don't
waste my life at the grocery store and I
guess I'm so lazy.
I get them to leave them out front.
Um, and so we pick them
up. We got to pick him up.
Listen farts. Yes. No. How to,
do you want a fart? Can you
really fart? Do you want to Fart?
Bark. Bark with me. You
think of this kid? We,
uh, this was, did you discover this
kid or is it, was he sent in? Um,
I think someone send a man. Okay. The
Fo this kid is kind of interesting.
It's not always the,
the,
the physically strongest
who wins the battle. No.
And it's not always the fastest. Right.
Or the smartest.
Right.
Sometimes it's the person
with the most stand Hima
yeah. You know, that's the
stand on my guys. Yup. Wow.
It's generations. Do you think
so? Yeah. I think with the, um,
like I said,
I don't know if I mentioned this,
I was a top spelling bee champion
in the state of California to,
you've actually mentioned it quite a few,
top 10.
And part of the problem
is this shorthand texting.
I, I'm guilty. Do you have it? I don't
write out the word your anymore. I write.
You are, you know, Idk. I don't know
that was an accident, but it's
still like, this is great.
Thank you. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it's a, it's because
kids don't read as much anymore,
I'm assuming. Right. Well what, um,
what gave you that clue? Dan Anima.
The Anima. Let's see,
what about that? Again,
I've mispronounced words that I've
seen written for years, you know?
Yeah. He does not remember I, what's
the word I fucked up on our show?
Pretty recent.
Con Con.
It was a, yeah. Sounded like that. Oh,
combative. Combative. Right. You're like,
I've been reading that in my head is
combatitive. Yeah, it's combative, right?
Yeah.
But then my mother would mispronounce
words and I heard her wrong for years.
Children of a foreign English speakers,
foreign accent syndrome.
So we get it.
We get it bad cause it's
your developmental area and
you're hearing all these
things set incorrectly and your case
by both parents. Both of them. Yeah.
The what
tomorrow.
Yeah. Pretty great stuff. Good words.
Sometimes it's winning a battle map.
Part of it is to get your rest and get
your energy and your stand up going
before wait,
before you enter the ring,
the ring called real life.
You're not going to win in real
life if you're standing was so low.
He sounds like he almost got it right.
Stamp Stammer
when in real life if you're
standing was so low closed.
What's interesting
is that we shame people like him.
No shame for all these other dumb things,
but we don't shame people for
just being straight stupid. Right.
If we started a stupid shaming campaign,
I think it would look cool with that.
I'm cool shaming a this kid over,
since Stan Stan stand up.
That's how he's going to learn
that word when in real life,
if your standards are so low,
if you shame him enough,
he'll learn how to say it correctly for
the rest of his life. It is interesting.
The idea too
much more.
I don't know why we stopped shaming.
No shame is a,
is a good instrument for
change. I agree. You should be.
She had to write this down.
Testing how this guy is doing
kind of self help stuff.
Interesting. Like Tony Robbins,
but look at him. You know,
it's kind of interesting.
It needs the help. Yeah.
It looks like he should maybe
read more of those books.
That's why rest is
important. Right. Important.
So if you want feel like taking a nap,
you should take a nap. Yeah. Gloves.
Oh, you should stay down
until you get better. Yeah.
See that's it's always a sign of
intelligence is fingerless gloves.
It's just a, I think it's just a side
of really hard time taking a nap bad.
You should stay down until you get better.
That's good advice that
you'll win the bet. Match Mat
or how about this? Like if you, if
you stammer through your video, yeah,
maybe recorded again. Right.
Make it better. Nope, you
don't have time for that.
This guy doesn't,
he's a guru.
Stop worrying about losing all these
fake girls because you know why?
Why, why they're diamond doesn't
true. What one real woman,
one real woman that's going to love you
and respect you to the Anton is worth
habit.
Maybe sometimes it's best to wait it out.
That was good advice. Good advice.
Yeah, that's actually good advice.
Yeah,
that was good. Here's what I want to
know. Are you talking to yourself?
Okay.
How old is this kid? He's never had
a real woman I know. Talking about.
So come and dock. Dave
should hang out. Okay.
Say you win this girl shop at hot
topic and you find some similar item.
You Buy Similac.
You know something interesting to talk
about his girl shop at hot topic and you
find some similar item.
You find a flannel,
you know there's something interesting
to talk about. Yeah. You know,
wearing the same shirt.
I assume Ila item a similar,
I tell him in La,
maybe his parents were foreign.
Look, I'm not a pickup artist. Huh?
I'm just some wait a mirrored
who knows the lighting?
Who knows a little bit about gay?
Okay. Oh, I'm going to know who guy.
I'm just a regular ass.
Do you? Okay, bad boy.
Get your bracelets.
You know what?
I always think about the brain
and I know his comicon and, and,
and you know geek girls and I'm gonna
tell you a geek girls have the same run
the same way as other
girls do. Yeah, yeah.
Right there at the
friendship. Yeah. That is a,
a friendship did to get your bad
boy bracelets. Yup. Yup. Yup. Tom,
have you been working on
your bad boy accessories?
Are you a fucking bad boy
or not? Yeah, I think so.
Get the bracelets.
They up.
The stay on and all this shit's
jumping on different screens.
Yeah. They should really start shaming
people for misspellings and uh, you know,
and saying things wrong medically
incorrect things and uh,
like intelligence things. People should
be shamed for their lack of intelligence.
I think so. Absolutely. Because are you
can kind of control only if you're trying.
I think you should be shamed if you're
trying to tell somebody what's up,
what's up and then you're the dog. In the
case of these videos, he's the preacher,
right? He's informing them,
telling you how to live.
You're allowing us to up our stand on
up stand alone. Yeah. I don't know.
I think across the board,
which just started shaming campaign and
here's the most important thing ever.
Respect.
Don't let someone take advantage of you
or make you spend all their money on
them and just act like a little bitch boy.
Okay.
Think he's done that. Yeah. Yeah.
Now you realize that these videos are
for himself. Well, yeah, of course.
Of course. Yeah. Poor guy.
I understand his money.
Just remember to follow you on advice.
You're not going to win in real life
if you're standing was so low. True.
Get out there.
You have the Dan Umma Stat.
Stamats Stan, Emma, my nose. Um,
a lot of people really impressed that
your mom's house was featured on 60
minutes and it's not every day that a
show of that caliber features a podcast.
Um, but with us it happens and
we were very proud of it. Um,
if you didn't catch the
little segment they did, um,
it was on the anniversary of the
Cincinnati Fart and it really was pretty
substantial. It was surprised that
Morley safer covered the piece.
Yeah. I didn't think they'd send
him. Is it because he's dead?
Exactly right. Yeah. Well, he came
back from the dead to do this.
Do the piece. I know. Yeah. No, he,
they did one thing about
morally, it's that he, he,
he really does have that shaver and his
face was melting off of his skull and he
died the moment after he
retired
and I met him at the door
and then it happened.
It shut the room.
I've never been around anything like
that before. It's a little loud.
I got a dad that really far.
It's good afternoon.
Thank you for just coming to
Venice on Cincinnati downtown.
How may I direct your call? Hi Ya.
Um, do you get to consume one book,
a room to commemorate this Cincinnati
Fart that happened last year
to commemorate what? I'm
sorry, could you repeat that?
The Cincinnati fart anonymous
caller at our hotel.
There's
something called the Cincinnati Fart.
Right?
It sounds like you're familiar with
it a little bit. Yeah. Well, I,
I went on this river cruise and they
had a really big buffet and I was six
months pregnant. So like I ate
way more than I normally would.
Lasagna, chicken, pork, Broccoli, garlic,
mashed potatoes, two helpings of
bread. I had four desserts that day.
And then I took a nap
right after. Yeah. I mean,
after dinner I went back
to the room and you know,
she greeted me and I was just
expecting to have a normal night,
but it was anything but normal.
What did it sound like?
Oh,
by the way,
Caitrin wasn't that good and that's why
I farted so big. The food was garbage.
It was like a garbage buffet and I eat
every piece of garbage on the table.
True. I mean me, look at me. I really
had some great farts in my life,
but nothing like the
Cincinnati Fart is legendary.
The longest fart I ever
had in my entire life.
And it was amazing. I mean the, the
carpets changed color in that room.
Painting started appeal. It
was really, really disgusting.
Oh my God, you guys are so
disgusting. This isn't any far.
It was a legit 25 second plus Fart.
I think the room was still smells.
I'd be surprised if it didn't. Yeah,
that room does have this,
but they do make me do my drains,
but it still comes back.
Not sure what it is.
It was like garbage on top
of vomit and on top of shit.
Worst thing I've ever smelled. People
ask me, Christina, how can I fart?
Like you eat bad food.
It's just that simple.
I'm not your Fart Guru, but I can tell
you what you can do to help yourself.
You can eat
bad today. Let us not only
remember our fallen soldiers,
but let us also remember
the Cincinnati Fart.
What was so special about that room?
The Cincinnati Fart.
Could you spell that for me?
Yeah.
F A r t like passing gas.
Um, can I put you on a
brief hold? Sure. Yeah.
Thank you. Yes. Good work. Wow.
Blue Band band did that working with 60
minutes. Yeah. Was that fun to work with?
That whole crew and Morley's
dead body SEL pros do is real.
It's real cool to learn. Yeah.
Wow. Really Neat. I'm proud of us.
I am worthy chamber
and there's the smell when you
enter the city of Cincinnati,
that cannot be explained,
but we may have found the answer.
Vague droopy dog eyes. Droopy dog.
No woman like that's on Tele. No,
they never let it run on TV looking
that Shitty fucking only dudes. Um,
all right. We got, we gotta run genes.
Okay. Thank you guys for listening.
Uh, here is the closing song.
It's now I'm in your ass. Yeah.
The street justice remix. Is that Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah. That's the closing song. Yeah.
I think you'll like it. Okay. Oh,
okay. Um, Oh God, we love you.
I love you.
Blah hall at mom's house.
Bye Bye. Dot. Seriously.
No
Bet.
Yeah.
Whoa.